[Applause]
hello everybody thank you very much
Thank You BAFTA hello guests friends
many thanks for being afforded the
chance to speak on a subject so
mercurial so elusive we can only pretend
to know what we are talking about when
we are talking about it
the dark art the lonely art the bloody
difficult art the under celebrated art
that dare not speak its name but we will
speak it the screenplay in the late 90s
I live for a couple of years in Los
Angeles where how to screenwriting books
were in every bookstore on route to
being in every apartment everyone had
seemed wanted the Midas touch to write
Martin Scorsese's next picture and to
eventually be able to deliver master
classes on the lucrative master class
circuit these books were everywhere and
I remember one title in particular it
was really popular the 90 day screenplay
it was a best-seller when it came out an
absolute Bible for many and it gave
every taxi driver and secretary and
busboy the sense that the big time was
close at hand how close well just 90
days and $15.00 away but this book's
days at the top of the nonfiction
bestseller lists were numbered for a new
Bible was soon to appear and the 90 days
screenplay was duly knocked off its
perch by a sensational new bestseller
how to write a movie in 21 days
clearly the letter was a superior book
by some margin I mean same result 61
days less time and a publishing pattern
had thereby been established soon we had
Darrin Donnelly and his brother Travis
stepping up to the plate dan and trebs
book was called the ten days screenplay
Wow
apparently Dara and Trev had found a way
to write an insight to be written nine
feature films of similar or better
quality than their predecessors in the
exact same timeframe that the 90-day
screenplay could only produce one things
were heating up and begging the question
would records continue to be broken as
the history of the 100-meter dash has
shown we have not yet reached the
maximum speed at which screenplays can
be written but there is of course a
logical terminal velocity the fastest
speed at which you can humanly type 120
pages the ultimate title therefore we
may yet see the 80 words a minute
screenplay speed aside all these books
have something in common they tell the
same story they have identified key key
qualities that many commercially
successful screenplays share they have
codified a language that has been
adopted by creative executives in both
film and television in my experience
these books won't hurt you they're not
harmful to writers at any rate they are
only harmful to producers and to funders
finance ears why because books like this
provide producers and funders a template
and a vocabulary by which to measure and
critique screenplays to allow them to
say where and how they don't conform to
certain moot
whose purpose is to minimize the risk to
their financial investment the
executives are entitled to this position
and are expressly employed to decline
uninsurable ideas those too risky
proposals that have no successful
precursors their position is entirely
sane but this has resulted in a
landscape where as the screenwriter you
will always always be asked to define
your story in terms of the classic
three-act structure because it's then
that those who fly business class will
feel that they have their best shot at
evaluating its potential footnote number
one they will never ask you to present
your idea as a 5 act structure because
no one actually knows what that is so to
survive in the business it's necessary
to understand the pressure that produces
and Finance ears operate under as such
you have to know what a three-act
structure is fortunately it's pretty
simple reason perhaps for its broad
appeal and here it is
act 1 the [ __ ] hits the fan
part two our sorry Act two part a the
hero has no choice but to act midpoint
realization of initial goal but first
appearance of a greater goal Act two
Part B even more [ __ ] hits multiple fans
ending in a river of excrement in which
the hero was more or less submerged
otherwise known as the lowest point act
3 with the clock now ticking and the
hero digging deep the river is drained
most of the fans but not all cleaned the
hero reaching a higher state of maturity
and reconciliation so there we have it a
mold a super famously successful mold
into which you can now pour your slurry
of words when it sets you will have a
screenplay and will at least look like a
screenplay read like a screenplay
conform to the expectations of a
screenplay and may possibly be saleable
as a screenplay but is it any good does
it have anything fresh and new to say
and does it employ exciting new ways to
say it well those are other questions
entirely and the only ones we should
spend any time discussing one of the
nice things about preparing to give a
talk like this is that it's forced me to
think about how I do what I do something
I've never before felt inclined to do I
honestly don't know where I am and my
own personal climb but till now I've
never looked down never taken stock and
perhaps thought it in it it thought it
in advisable to do so so when I began to
consider what I might talk about today I
first asked myself well where am I now I
mean right now the answer without false
modesty is that wherever I am it feels
like a good place and by most systems of
measure it's better than ever
a place where
at least feel like I am able to take on
more and achieve more than I ever have
before
fewer things intimidate me and the
rejections which never stop by the way
are fewer and less impactful while the
times when I'm told I've knocked it out
of the park have increased so maybe
maybe I've gotten good at what I do and
if I can afford to let myself think that
then it begs a big question
ok then bright guy what changed how did
you get good and is the answer useful to
anyone else
well we're about to find out the facts
are that I'm currently working on five
major feature film projects concurrently
with some of the biggest film companies
and some of the best directors in the
world and I'm finding that I can handle
it
I'm required to jump between these
projects at any given hour on any given
day and I find I can handle it and the
pressure of expectation at this point is
considerable but I'm handling it 20
years ago for certain I would not have
been able to handle it for sure no
chance so what changed what makes the me
of now any more capable than the me of
yesteryear is there any difference why
am I now able to handle what hitherto
would have overwhelmed me my attempt to
answer this question is your fault
better you started this so don't blame
me so let's go now there is such mystery
surrounding the craft of screenwriting
with so many different theories out
there about how it's done that our
industry has felt it necessary to nail
down a few basic rules golden rules I
want to quickly mention some of the big
ones
but let me add another big caveat if
these rules were any good
then simply by following them you'd
perforce end up with a superb end
product but the fact is this these rules
only work sometimes I've had now some 25
years trying to make films and almost
everything I will say today can be just
as convincingly contradicted when I make
a definitive statement bear in mind the
opposite can also be true for instance
strong arguments could be made for the
following heresies one right what you
don't know so that your personal
journeys is an exploration in other
words right what you want to know did
Shakespeare visit Venice did Jules Verne
go to the moon and back to tell it don't
show it sometimes it's better to hear
about it than to see it what comes out
of a human mouth can have more emotional
value than any toppling skyscraper when
the lovers kiss at last perhaps it's
better to fade to black number three
never let your characters tell you where
the story should go you're paid to be in
charge your characters are your slaves
no more order them around brutally they
may not be animals but to paraphrase
Hitchcock they should be treated like
animals for structure is nothing
structure is nothing it is as TS Eliot
once put it just the meat you throw the
guard dog so you can get inside and rip
the joint off 2001 a Space Odyssey is
one of the greatest films ever made
partly because its structure is
indiscernible it is a vacation from
narrative so now we have heard from the
rebels the chrome contrarians we can
move on and discuss iron caste
principles that I have found useful
sometimes but not always powerful truths
that have worked on some occasions and
not others golden rules that have only
once or twice paid dividends for those
needing certainties I give you the exits
so how do you write a screenplay so good
that millions that people will invest
millions of dollars to see it made and
millions of people will shell out to go
and see it evaluating the potential of
your idea imagine the situation you have
a concept for a film a pitch you hope to
sell you go into your you go into a room
and want to convince money minded
executives that your idea is going to
make them a a lot of money or B make
them no money at all and possibly lose
some but will gain them some kudos at
awards time that in turn may make them
feel better about themselves when
they're old
the moment arrives you're invited to
speak to present your idea no matter how
well you do it and pitching is a science
in science in itself which we don't have
time to go into now you are asking them
to make an enormous leap of faith it's
as if you were trying to sell someone a
car when all you have are a select few
of the cars parts lying around on your
front lawn you are an effect telling
them to look at a few extracts from the
car you have in mind and imply there's
more where that came from
to their valid question about whether
your proposed motor vehicle will ever
run you reply for sure absolutely what
will be the range and speed of the
vehicle they then ask your reply oh well
we will have to make it first but we
plan to ensure that it will be a miracle
of economy and performance quite unlike
any other car previously manufactured
when then asked to offer some proof for
this claim you struggle to provide it
maybe just saying well you'll have to
trust me I'm describing it in this way
because I think it's useful to put
yourself and the producers funders shoes
it is very hard to evaluate what will
work and what won't work and why these
executives are desperate to fall back on
some system event of evaluation this is
why producers and funders set so much
store in the power of the premise if
your film has a seductive premise you
have your best shot at winning over even
the most risk-averse producer or thunder
the premise is often called the elevator
pitch or car park pitch
it's the reductio absurdum of your
complex deeply nuanced idea into a
vulgar soundbite my second-to-last film
took 10 years to finance even though it
was about one of the most recognizable
and brilliant men in the cosmos why well
because my elevator
went like this quadriplegic gets
cuckolded and so writes a book merging
Einsteinian relativity with quantum
mechanics you can just see the film
company boss glazing over adjusting his
glasses on her nose glancing at a watch
with zero discretion and then asking me
what else you got by far the most
determining factor in a script being
good or better still great and by far
the most decisive factor in getting it
made is the quality of your original
concept from this even the dimmest
financier will be able to weigh its
commercial viability it is a truism that
if you have a million-dollar idea you
don't have to be a very good writer to
write a saleable script get the film
made and even be successful but if you
have a mediocre or lousy idea for a film
your name could be William Shakespeare
and you won't be able to get it off the
ground unless you hang out with Megan
Ellison when I was 25 years old I wrote
with a friend of mine a stage play in
three weeks
my buddy Stephen came over said hey why
don't we write a play about male
strippers
maybe he'd been drinking and I said gee
I'm not sure Stephen I know I don't know
much about male strippers about how
about we write a play about some regular
guys who think it it'll be easy to be
male strippers so we did that it was a
good idea a good idea is a good idea and
and can prove impervious even to
slapdash craftsmanship in fact this
particular idea was so good it just
sailed away became New Zealand's most
commercially successful play of all time
and continues to play around the world
25 years later so why did it take off it
was a good and universally appealing
idea I tried many other times to find
another one just like it
not so easy great ideas of rare birds
you see you need binoculars
you need you need to keep a to keep real
quiet
and you need to know what you're looking
for so where the good ideas come from I
hear you asking where to find great
stories with strong premises a in your
own personal story be in the nation's
history and culture see in your
community D and other cultures e and
other stories that have gone before F in
your imagination entirely G and all the
above my advice is the only advice is
look everywhere inside and out and look
all the time part of being a
professional is never being off duty
the hours are lousy but it's seldom
boring learn to notice with any luck
you'll come up with one or two or three
really great ideas in your lifetime most
writers would settle for one the rest of
the time you're trying to make the
mediocre ones work don't beat yourself
up about it we're all in the same lousy
boat great ideas are rare and here's
something else a great idea isn't even
isn't ever delivered to you hole with
all the elements in the right place the
least I've never been gifted one great
ideas are made by you the germ of a
great idea isn't a film until you've
cracked the story the internal engine of
the story has to be made to work reality
is messy and history is a lousy
filmmaker and the writer's job is to
lick it all into shape sometimes you can
see how to do this from the off these
are the best projects you can see right
away how the idea might be turned into a
story that can work and you have to know
what to look for here's what I look for
in order of importance 1 a story in
which I can foresee before I've written
a single word most of the major twists
and turns in that journey two characters
who I can't wait to gain control of to
subordinate to make them do or say
things that are so
stream and and out of the ordinary that
they're almost unacceptable three a
bittersweet ending
I believe perfect bliss is the preserve
of cats small children drunks and idiots
importantly for me I need to sense the
ending before I begin for only then will
I know how to tell the story in the
right way
plan your story if this sounds
unromantic screenwriters are not tasked
to be poets you can and should keep a
certain analytical distance from your
work for finally a story with dimension
with some cultural importance or
personal significance a story that
contains issues I am burning to examine
and which will take me into some extreme
of human experience the prospect of
telling the story must stir you to great
excitement this excitement will be
tested and will diminish as you struggle
with the telling so make sure you have a
huge reserve and of of it before you
begin let me expand on these points
number one no one knows where good ideas
come from if we did we'd go there more
often but we can agree at least that
they are around us all the time and the
task is to notice them number two as I
say a great idea isn't ever delivered to
you whole the story has to be cracked
Hollywood producers will pay a great
deal of money to a writer if they can
crack a story work out how to tell it in
a compelling way the internal engine of
the story has to be made to work
sometimes you can see how to do this
they are the best projects three
character in a fiction a person's
character is their fate so know the fate
where this character has to end up in
your story and then select the character
traits appropriate to that fate in a
nonfiction project you don't quite have
that flexibility but you can still make
them do and
say what you need them to do and say in
order to in order to honor the film's
theme number four humor I always look
for some element of humor to me no story
if it is to make a claim of being true
to life can be devoid of humor
almost every meaningful human
interaction you will ever have will
include some attempt at humor it's the
standard currency of conversation and
how human beings do business humor is
part of the ritual of negotiation so if
you want your stories to feel real and
truthful
don't forget about humor number four
know your ending before you begin for me
I never feel I have a grip on on a story
until I know the destination or have at
least a sense of it in fact I never take
a project on unless I know the ending
and I'm convinced it's a powerful one
now not all writers will agree with this
many writers write freestyle
spontaneously making it up as they go
with no idea where their story is going
they say that this is what makes the
process feel exciting and artful almost
spiritual the next step being the only
important one but personally I found
that those writers who are most vocal
about their opposition to structure and
formula and planning out their story are
invariably crap its structure and
formula and planning out their story
Harold Pinter never planned any of his
plays really well it shows I love his
plays but it shows the plays are
indisputable masterpieces but their
endings are the weakest part and in a
movie or week ending as a deal breaker
with endings being so important in
movies because it's what the audience
takes away it's a very brave writer
indeed and a very brave producer who
will spend years on a project where the
ending as the weakest part of the
screenplay
I sometimes feel I need to know what my
ending is first because I just don't
have the guts to go through all those
months of uncertainty and doubt and
self-hatred and expect expect and
personal loathing tied up with not
knowing where the hell I'm going and
it's true writers who write without a
plan will all tell you the same thing
halfway through the writing process the
misery starts major perturbation as the
original impulse weakens as a mess
develops in the middle as problems pop
up in probabilities forced transitions
this way of working always gets the
writer down it's migraine inducing
anxiety spawning simply the freestyle
writer will suffer more than the
structuralist and I began as a
freestyler who believed his intuitions
would carry him to victory so I'm
speaking from experience I learned
eventually that lack of planning will
always catch up with you God will not
always provide let me give you an
example of a perfect ending one that
could only have been achieved by a
structuralist an author knowing exactly
where she was going before picking up
her pen here it is there was a young man
from Hibernia who rhymed himself into a
hernia he became quite adept at rhyming
except for the odd anti-climax
take a bow mr. Stoppard you will excuse
the irony that the ending is not an
anti-climax at all quite the contrary
now this is a perfect example of a
perfect ending for two reasons
the final line had to be known before
the first line was written it was of
course the reason the poem was written
and it and it dictated these preceding
lines secondly while being about an
anti-climax it's anything but an
anti-climax
it's the perfect climate climax because
it delivers satisfaction in a way we
were tricked into not being able to
foresee but which when it arrives
superseded our expectations the rhyme
patent promised us a final line that
would rhyme with Hibernia and then the
author detonated our expectations and
delightfully because the author had
something even better up his clever
sleeve that he has craft Tilly set up
for us know your ending I personally
never decide to work on a project unless
I know the ending and know that it
satisfies my own personal criteria for a
good and worthwhile climax okay so let's
say you had an idea for an interesting
premise and you've come up with a really
satisfying end point that delivers in an
unexpected way on the potentials of that
premise how do you write the hundred or
so pages in between
well you reverse engineer your story
what do I mean by reverse engineer I
mean that the ending will dictate almost
everything you need to know about the
story that precedes it character plot
theme and structure example if your film
is about a talented Pig who wants to run
faster than any Pig is ever run before
and you have seen the ending and
foreseen it involving porky winning the
hundred meters
the Olympics then the task is to instill
in your audience for the preceding 100
minutes a subconscious craving to see a
pig its arms and legs pumping hurtling
down the track to victory that's your
job but it must be a victory the author
has tricked the audience into not quite
being able to anticipate if at any point
it's too evident to the audience that
bovine gold is where the story is headed
there no swine on a dais will save you
if they can see it coming they will hate
you for it we can call the sleight of
hand
concealment of true intentions the film
at the outset must one way or the other
ask a question that your secret ending
will answer but not in the way they had
expected it to be answered he became
quite adept at rhyming except someone
mister stopped out of his presence for
the air odd anticlimax on the point that
you're ending contains the clues you
need for how to write the preceding
hundred pages here are two examples
imagine a climactic scene that occurs on
top of the Eiffel Tower then it may make
you decide to create a character who in
the first act suffers from vertigo if
the character has vertigo this may then
oblige scenes to explain why the
character suffers from vertigo the
writer's job is to earn the emotion they
wish the audience to feel and you earn
it by setting up setting it up in a way
that ensures the biggest payoff the
Deerhunter one of the greatest films is
a masterpiece of reverse engineering the
ending involved DeNiro in Saigon playing
Russian roulette with another man in
order to save his life to make us care
about the outcome and to make it
powerful the writers decided to make the
two men spiritual brothers make them
familiar with gunplay and go further
make them brothers pledge
look after one another no matter what
how about even make them in love with
the same woman so that maybe if one of
them dies it simplifies their love life
but make them noble also so we don't
want either of them to die and then the
gun goes off and one of them dies our
heart breaks but not because the gun
went off not at all if the film had
started with the scene that scene we
wouldn't have cared we care because of
all the scenes we have seen in the
previous two hours we think of the
pledge the woman their families back
home they're lost simple dreams
in short no you're ending something else
I've learned along the way which rises
logically from this example if there are
problems in your third act
the real problem is probably in your
first or second act it's not the ending
that isn't satisfying it's your setup
the ending is fine it's probably why you
wrote this script in the first place or
should have done but you can't believe
your great ending isn't working for
people the gun went off why is no one
crying answer you didn't create the
right sets of preconditions that would
establish audience anticipation for your
obligatory but unpredictable ending that
sentence will sound like gibberish but
it actually isn't so I'll say it again
if there are problems in your third act
the real problem is in the first act
you just didn't create the right sets of
preconditions that would establish
audience anticipation for your
obligatory but unpredictable ending your
Eiffel Tower climax isn't satisfying
because you are omitted to give your
hero vertigo in the first date if your
climax involves a reconciliation and it
isn't satisfying it's because the
earlier conflict wasn't deep enough so
that it made us ache for reconciliation
make us ache for your wonderful ending
but be unable to see what form the
reconciliation will come in
my personal list of favorite
screenwriters are all reverse engineers
retrofit as nonpareil robert bolt Alfred
Hitchcock Billy Wilder the Coen brothers
Woody Allen paddy Chayefsky William
Goldman and my favorite screenplays all
showed the fingerprints of the right and
knowing their ending first and writing
toward it in the most elegant and
satisfying way Lawrence of Arabia
Godfather 1 & 2 Jean de florette Raging
Bull Casablanca Once Upon a Time in
America all the President's Men star
wars now you don't have to work this way
and many people don't it's just the best
ones all do you may plan nothing and
just get lucky with your ending it
happens one of my favorite New Zealand
films smash palace was a film where the
filmmakers didn't have a clue how to end
it it's director Roger Donaldson told me
that during the writing process
he and his co-writer Peter Hansard
didn't have an ending and they were
completely stumped their lead actor
Bruno Lawrence a famous drinker and
smoker and bon vivant came by to check
on the progress of the screenplay
and was so dismayed by the possibility
that the film would die for lack of an
ending he promptly fell asleep on the
couch while the director and producer
continued to bang their heads against
the wall deep into the night apparently
what happened then was that eventually
Bruno woke up in a moment of delirious
inspiration envisaged a car on a railway
line his character a Kirk holded husband
holding a sawn-off shotgun to the head
of his wife's lover as a speeding train
hurtles towards them their mutual
destruction certain a quite good ending
in itself pretty dark until at the last
minute the train falls away something
the husband had planned for the tracks
bifurcating just before the train
reaches the car the train not harming
anyone but eliciting a confession from
the terrified lover rolling credits they
had their ending
delivered perfectly on the premise of
the film but the moral is this unless
you have a bruno lawrence lying on your
couch at 3:00 a.m. i would caution
against this approach create a keen
anticipation for an ending we cannot
foresee i want to switch now to the
issue of how to make yourself a better
writer and no matter what your story is
how do you make yourself fundamentally
better at what you do there is a simple
answer and it's this make yourself
talented talent isn't something you
either have or don't have talent is
acquired it is one it is the result of
hard work and more hard work only then
will you become talented some acquire it
early during childhood as a natural
extension of a sustained period of
mental engagement others develop it
later become talented after the age of
fifty when a perhaps dormant interest is
suddenly reawakened practice creates
mastery and repeated exercise of that
mastery creates talent it doesn't come
with your mother's milk or by going to
an expensive school it's inside you
waiting to come out if you have the guts
to draw it out over time if you work
hard enough you can set free capacities
inside you that you may currently not
imagine you even have so what is the
exact process by which this can be
achieved
how can anyone become talented when I
started writing in my 20s I had
developed through my interest in
language a certain aptitude and
sensitivity for language but I was by no
one's estimation and I mean no one's and
certainly not even my own talented these
days not even my harshest critics would
say I'm entirely devoid of talent so
what happened
talent is meant to be like your hair
color you can fake being a brunette but
sooner or later everybody's
going to find out the truth when I
assess myself I can say without blushing
that I am better now at what I do
then I used to be so how did this happen
what made the difference what was the
change agent at work was it simply a
factor of age and becoming more worldly
wise or something even more mysterious
well I have a theory about this and it's
even supported now by science so I'll
share it with you because it's pretty
good news for all of us neuro scientists
have only recently been looking at the
matter of aptitude and some very recent
studies have come up with some pretty
spectacular findings one study focused
on two thousand black cab drivers in
London London is not laid out like a
grid it's an impossible huge maze you
don't need to be told but black cab
drivers in order to get their license
are forced to know every single street
by street and these guys are not rocket
scientists many never finish school
it takes them years to learn every
Street and to remember it and what
researchers found to their amazement is
that cabbies have grown a significantly
larger hippocampus than the ordinary
person the hippocampus in the brain
controls spatial awareness and it turns
out that the brain mass of cabbies grew
to meet the extraordinary demands being
placed upon their memories everyday and
we can apply this example to
screenwriting or any creative activity
to become adept at screenwriting the
only way the only way to gain mastery is
not by buying Darrin and Travis
Donnelly's ridiculous book but by making
huge and sustained demands upon the
networks of your brain that govern
creativity now we're I to write a book
on the subject and stuff it into la
bookstores
it'll be laughed out of town for what
might we call it screenwriting made hard
or give me ten years and I'll make you a
star but actually I think this is the
closest we've come to a true
understanding of what it takes to get
real good at all extremely real good at
all extremely complex and difficult
tasks I'm sure we all grew up being
aware of the old right-brain left-brain
model right brain people work in banks
and know what a square root is left
brain people drink Beaujolais and
discuss Kierkegaard and a little bit
effete but it turns out this is all
wrong instead the truth as it often is
is much much more interesting we now
know that creativity the entire creative
process from preparation to incubation
to illumination to verification four
stages consists of many interacting
cognitive processes both conscious and
unconscious as well as involving
emotions all operating in vast networks
that reconfigure depending on what stage
of the creative process you're engaged
in for instance every time you try to
figure out how to work spatially such as
trying to work out the structure of your
screenplay you will be using the same
part of your brain the dorsal attention
visio spatial network that we use when
we try to fit luggage into the trunk of
your car when we go on holiday or if you
are trying to write a lyrical passage a
climactic speech at the end of your film
where the sound of each word is vital
then you will make greater demands on
the Lange language network in the broker
area when jazz musicians and rappers
engage in creative improvisation while
in a flow state they will call upon the
imagination and executive attention
networks writers however can't afford
such uninhibited freedom unless you are
Charlie Kaufman
so must bring the salience Network back
online to critically evaluate and
implement your creative ideas so it
seems and this is the bad news for
Travis and Darrin if you want to become
a really if you want to become really
talented as a creative person then you
will need to develop these large-scale
brain networks and we are talking about
training and literally growing the brain
to match the tasks all in an
apprenticeship of years
no nine-day shortcuts what this means is
that wannabe screenwriters with an
interest in being talented can be so but
these screenwriters will need to write
one script then another then another
then another until their minds are
bursting like a London cabbie driven mad
trying to remember every twist and turn
in the journey from Kensington church
Street to Wimbledon common and by the
way this information used to be
well-known this level of devotion and
concentration was actually standard in
the artistic academies of previous
centuries in pockets this ethos is still
understood the Florence Academy of Art
maintains the old masters standards to
this day their website for their five
year apprenticeship check it out five
years actually has this statement as
individual artists are challenged to
push the technical ability beyond their
perceived capacity they develop strength
of character and the confidence
necessary to become a professional this
helps create a state of mind in which
they are certain of their choices we're
going to show now three or four clips
the first is from the theory of
everything so we can pull something up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was the ending of the movie there
and that was the ending I knew before I
started I knew that Stephens life was
devoted to many things but principally
the subject he kept being fascinated by
was time so the unifying principle of
that entire movie was time and when I
had the idea that the movie should at
the end reverse time and we should see
the the contents of his entire life that
that's when I sort of set out to tell
that story so that's an example of that
okay next could Doctor
[Music]
dr. Stephen Hawking and his astonishing
he's the first person to receive as
doctorates bearing mine had a little
work was the worst four letter word for
steven linder oxford especially he
averaged an hour an hour a day the
average on the theme of slovak right and
how many of your lectures have I covered
in the last six months
when you've been doing research trips
[Music]
well everything alright
Hey
[Music]
that is the final image there is of the
able-bodied small child and being kind
of the the adult in there and Steven
sort of reduced to being an infant who
can't get up the stairs sometimes when
you're dealing with them true stories
you you went history and the facts just
give you these gems Jane's book was a
very very difficult book to adapt it
didn't have an obvious structure but it
was full of these moments which was so
tremendously heartbreaking and and that
was one of them I added the child at the
top of the stairs that's kind of what
you do you take reality and then you can
you walk meant it to reach a sort of
deeper truth to make it live in your
consciousness even more okay
next cut
I have hastily to travel with me to
America she will look after me
who's she
yes
you always used to tell me when an
invitation came in another award what
can you do
I am sorry
of many years
they said - you've had so many
everything will be okay
I have loved you
I did my best
[Music]
we were all in tears on onset watching
that particular one part of it again
part of the reason for wanting to tell
the story is a very universal moment a
breakup between a husband and wife
completely recovered a million times and
movies but never I felt having to
mediate through a computer what would
that be like I asked myself before I
started writing the project how can you
how would some simplest things be done
if you had to speak through a computer
the Boris Lee write out the words
there's I think the 75 words in that
scene and it starts with a moment of
marital triumph
where Stephen has conceded that there
might be a god which is very important
to the very religious Jane and by 75
years words later they're divorced which
I'm quite proud of for someone who's
very devoted to words it was quite a
feat of economy but it was only possible
through the exquisite level of emotion
and nonverbal transference of
information and feeling that these
actors were able to achieve and then
seen okay next one okay I think we're
going to darkest hour here by mister
the question of peace talks we must know
don't yellow signal only that we intend
to fight it out until the end peace
offer to hele grave shall we can agree
and even if we were beaten we should be
no worse off than we should be if we
were now to abandon the struggle let us
therefore avoid being dragged down the
slippery slope with talk of a negotiated
peace slippery slope the only suspect
Italy and Germany so deeply involved in
negotiations that we should be a people
to turn nonsense by stoning in for my
proposal asleep please stop interrupting
me while I am interrupting you when I
serves my walk ever did I do take care
to surround myself with old rivals I may
have overdone it
I can tell affects your preps you
propose it's not only its few child but
it involves to see the deadly danger the
deadly danger here is this romantic
fantasy of fighting to the end
[Music]
what is the end if not the destruction
of all things
there's nothing heroic and going down
fighting if it can be avoided nothing
even remotely patriotic in death or
glory if the odds are firmly on the
former nothing inglorious in trying to
shorten a war that we are clearly losing
losing you're not this still Europe is
lost
and before our forces are wiped out
completely now is the time to negotiate
in order to obtain the best conditions
possible Hitler will not insist on
outrageous terms he will know his own
weaknesses he will be reached when would
the lesson be learned when well then the
something learn anymore dictators must
be wound appeased good God given him its
privileges before we learn you cannot
reason with a tiger when your head is in
its mouth no pad yeah there by the way
that was Gary Oldman playing Winston
Churchill clearly unrecognizable the
reason for showing that seeing one of
the greatest and oldest principles of
dramas dialectic the idea of two people
arguing both with fixed and opposite but
equal positions
what is fantastically fun to play with
as a writer is to give the your antihero
the better argument in this case the
moral center of the movie changes in
that scene from Churchill to Halifax who
up till now has seemed a loathsome apisa
but in the scene he makes the the most
practical and life loving and humanistic
argument that peace we should never give
up on peace we should not stop exploring
it and what happens is a wonderful thing
for the audience is that their
allegiance has to shift it's their their
opinions are challenged and and the most
amazing thing can happen that you're
that you you you you go from an
entrenched position and you move you
adjust and and in that if we're capable
as an audience of shifting our position
then you know there's hope for the world
because most of the troubles in this
world seem to me
come from people in fixed positions who
can't conceive of any other idea other
than their own
okay next clip
thank you
just anyone you have a match say what
are you all staring yeah have you ever
seen the Prime Minister right the
underground this law what is your name
or who will send some and what do you do
mr. Wilson bricklayer sir yeah we should
have great need a bricklayer soon my
business will be looking up
hello fight month sir it looks like you
measure all babies look like me well
what is your name mrs. Jessie suddenly
this is Abigail Abigail Walker Marcus
Jesus Marcus Peters Agnes Dylan Agnes
Morris Micah mr. Baker Alice Simpson
Allison it's Margaret Jerome Lois you're
oh my mother was a tear oh my I expect
we're closely relates you please please
sit sit everyone Thank You mr. Baker so
how are you all
how are you all pairing up good good
spinach just as women we shall read them
yeah
let me ask you something that's been
weighing on my mind perhaps you can
provide me with an answer you the
British people what is your mood
is it with the conference confident how
confident very some people says the law
school how lost causes is the only ones
worth fighting for right yes now let me
ask you this if the worst came to pass
and and the enemy what to appear on
those no streets above what would you do
fight fight the fashion photo with
anything we can lay around some broom
handles if we must straight by straight
though another tape Piccadilly what if I
put it to you all that we might if we if
we are nicely get very favorable terms
for mr. Hitler if we enter into a peace
deal with him right now what would you
say to that
well we'll never give up no never
then out spake brave Horatius captain of
the gate to every man upon this earth
death cometh sooner or later and how can
man die better than facing fearful odds
for the ashes of his father's and the
temples of his gods
yeah
are you crying
yeah got you by blob a lot you know we
already all have to get used to it much
stop is this Westminster Westminster
it's my stop
[Applause]
and included that scene because it's
it's the one that's already the most
discussed scene in the entire film and
it's discussed because people invariably
ask did that scene happen do you have
evidence that Winston ever rode the
underground and the simple answer is
there's no evidence that he that the
scene ever took place so it goes on to a
much bigger question probably bigger
than we have time to deal with here as
to the limits of artistic license and
the point where that tips into artistic
licensures Ness it has to do with many
issues to do with the tolerances of
history and the tolerances of audiences
and the contract that you enter into
with an audience when you have the words
before the title based on a true story
but essentially if you're in the service
of the truth and you responsibly are
bringing in elements into a story that
you believe a consistent with that
character and consistent with that
historical moment then then I think
you're completely within your rights to
import a scene like that this to defend
a scene like that it's very easy for me
okhta debride the underground do we know
that he did no we have no evidence but
at this decisive moment in British
history when Winston was wobbling and he
wasn't sure whether to do a peace deal
with Hitler the the opinion of the
public that was that he that he was
receiving via polls was proved the
turning point for him so the dramatist
says well what am I going to do am I
going to have a scene with some poles
some two pieces of paper being put in
front of him on his desk and it says oh
the people's support fighting on or do I
have him go and meet the people now it's
consistent with his character that he
often went off grid and popped up among
the public to take the pulse of the
public so I bind those two things and
created a scene it's amazing how many
people
the best scene in the film and how many
think it's absurd or a breach of the of
the writers contract it I'm not quite
sure why it's it's controversial at all
because I think it's what it's what we
do I think it's our task
oh and we're compelled to use our
imagination and bring our imagination to
the telling of true stories even where
the facts you know are known so that
kind of almost concludes our evening I
want to wish you good luck for those who
like Mia workers in the vineyard of the
word you need a lot of it persistence is
everything dare to fail and may you all
in your living doing what you love
thank you for the invitation
[Applause]
this this so much I think to get em to
know um we're gonna have a a
conversation between ourselves and I
think I ran a little long there no no
you're perfect you are you're to the
minutes really yeah yeah we're gonna
conversation no more questions from the
floor after that I want to pick up um
specifically on what you said about
reverse engineering your story he find
the ending work out a way to get to that
ending that the audience is going to be
desperate to land on it but not expect
to get only you your two most recent
films darkest hour and the theory of
everything are both based on true
stories the incredibly well known men
whose achievements
I think Churchill in particular mm-hm
are not just widely known but quite well
understood by the general public so how
when you're adapting a true story can
you still take the audience to a point
in history that they're already aware
exists and still make it feel unexpected
well if you take darkest hour as an
example I began darkest hour and about
ten years ago and it was at a moment
when I realized that three of the
greatest speeches of all time were
written and delivered by Winston Spencer
Churchill and and within at one
four-week period
now it's extraordinary for for any
leader to create a speech that will you
know rival a soliloquy from Shakespeare
but he wrote three absolute doozies in a
four-week period and then I did a little
digging into research and thought what
compelled this can this outpouring of
magnificent rhetoric because it wasn't
it wasn't true of churches whole career
that he was turning out these great
speeches and and the fact were this
there was nothing less than the collapse
of Central and Western Europe under the
Nazi booed an enormous domestic pressure
at home to do a peace deal with that of
Hitler I didn't know about that the
peace deal with that of Hitler on
it's kind of airbrushed out of history
and and I think the person most wielding
the airbrush is Winston himself he I
think he devoted like a paragraph to it
in his huge history of Sycamore so it
was like oh there's news here there's a
different man than than the one we
handed down from history so you know
that fitted in with all my little
obsessions that pedestals our four
statues and it's great to take heroes
down and you know make them human but
you have to have a have justification
for that and I just found him
wonderfully complicated and and flawed
and uncertain and and I thought okay now
this is a this is a movie worth making
because uncertainty to me rather than
being a negative is actually a
prerequisite and a leader because
uncertainty allows for the possibility
you may be wrong and if we have leaders
incapable of thinking that they may be
wrong we're all in deep [ __ ] it seems to
me there's a wonderful line that
Cromwell wrote to the Church of Scotland
and it goes like this he said I beseech
thee in the bowels of Christ think it
possible you may be wrong and I would
love that to be written above the
doorways of every world leader just
allow for that possibility and then
you'll be open minded so that's that's
the kind of that's where I start to know
my ending I know that I'm gonna create a
man who you you established them as as
one thing and then you make them
something else you present them as
something else
I saw the whole journey then given that
you built the film around these three
speeches or that was and the jumping-off
point for the screenplay and the
speeches are reasonably well known as as
political speeches go there very well um
do you feel there's an obligation to you
know give the audience
Churchill plays the hits I mean
was there a way in which you could bring
a fresh take to these speeches when you
say that or did you think okay we're
just gonna let these player and if
there's one moment I want to refer back
to specifically but in general fire
there was no in in the house of
parliament in the Commons there was no
recordings made of those speeches so in
fact the recordings we have have fight
them on the beaches and so forth was
made after the war I think 1946 and the
BBC said we should get a recording of
these because they were rather good and
so the Winston says alright I'll do it
I'll do it from my bed and there's a
photograph of him sitting in a little
fat pink in his onesie you know and he's
and if I've got a microphone dangling
from the ceiling and he did a very quiet
rendering of these speeches so the the
copies we have and not I don't and
Garrett this is Gary's observation too
that they're a poor representation of
what he would have delivered to eight
hundred parliamentarians because he was
a he was a showboater he was an actor so
he really was on a stage so when Joe
Wright filmed the scene and it's
extraordinarily beautifully done during
when you see the film we Joe didn't put
fifty people in as extras he bought an
eight hundred extras fully costumed Gary
came out there like Winston would have
done like an actor having to built those
lines to the back rows so that's a
completely different take on those great
speeches that audiences will never have
seen but but we think it's probably the
most accurate rendering you can ask for
a quick show of hands has anyone here
seen darkest hour yeah I know it so okay
so actually quite a few of you good okay
okay um
Churchill's maiden speech in Parliament
as Prime Minister there's something
incredibly unexpected in the way that
you present that where you have him
delivering the speech so first of all
that's of interest but then you set up
this kind of parallel thing running
where you have Chamberlain decides that
he's going to signal to his supporters
basically in the house whether or not
Churchill is to be accepted and as
his presence SPMS could be condoned and
this is going to be done by a gesture
with white handkerchief which
Chamberlain has sitting on his lap so as
an audience simultaneously while you're
listening to Churchill's speech you're
also this kind of parallel story is
ticking over in your head and it's it's
set up of course by the the two MPs
saying this is what he's gonna do and we
should look out for the very start no
tell me about taking something that's
like historically pre-existing and just
giving a bi extra that's another
technical term is like a huge extra
little tickle that is gonna make it
plain yeah even more cinematically than
perfect examples a perfect example of
reverse engineering so you you you know
you're gonna end up with this crime
acting scene and you know that the
dramas gonna depend on will he by this
speech when every heart in the house so
you I know that the Labour Party will be
sort of rooting for him will a
conservative supporter will the leader
do you know give the signal so I thought
okay I need some signal how would leader
communicate to the rest of his party who
are waiting on a gesture so I I just saw
chanced on the idea of a hankerchief so
I thought okay so at the end of the
movie I need him to pull out a
handkerchief oh I better established
that at the beginning of the movie and
Act one then so that's what we do so we
sit we set it up an Act one and and now
we all learn the sort of vocabulary of
this handkerchief that it's going to
signify this and then at the end of the
movie as you say it's not just about
what's what people are saying it's a
you're then all waiting so you get this
terrific emotional so a payload that
comes with just the gesture of one man
lifting a handkerchief it becomes quite
triumphant but it's not the gesture
itself it's all the work you did earlier
the fact that white handkerchief doesn't
look unlike a flag of surrender that
helps to write you can kind of a
lightened the perfect symbol for the
and when you tell your story here about
Churchill and there's the fate of
Europe's at stake there's his reputation
as a politician at stake so there's
different kind of things different
states on different levels and with the
theory of everything that's you know
you've got a story about a marriage in
crisis you've got a story about a man's
body the kind of medical story of his
physical breakdown and then also the
story of his cosmological discoveries
this is the theory of everything itself
and those are three types of story that
are quite I would think some who's never
tried to write a screenplay but they
seem they would be quite difficult to
reconcile in one story they would write
okay yeah so but when you were when you
were going through did anyone working
title or elsewhere can I see do we need
to have these three things happening
simultaneously or on the other hand did
they like the idea that this there's a
love story but there's also a science
bit but there's also a medical but
they're all moving parts and they and in
the process there are different moments
in the evolution of a screenplay where
it becomes apparent that you need to do
more with this one you need to put the
fader up on that one the fader down on
that one and that's what's terrific and
collegial about about the the filmmaking
process is there's so many people
helping you at a certain point to make
this better and you know presenting
arguments for even right down to the
actors with Kristin Scott Thomas saying
I'll do it but I want one more scene she
didn't actually say that but it became
apparent that she thought her role was
was kind of one scene to few and and and
she had damn good reason for thinking
that and so it was it was a it fell upon
me to to to write another little scene
for her but it wasn't just something for
her vanity or anything it was we can go
further with that character so you know
it's there's a lot of little movements
and stuff that you make and when you
work with the director and you work on a
director's pass they're trying to make
you know find a way to tell the story
cinematically so you then
again and you make the adjustments here
but it's all pretty much you've made the
suit now you have to make the suit fit
the client so you're taking it under the
arms and you're shortening this central
thing that and it's a bit of tailoring
and so forth it's it's all fascinating
process by that stage you're
specifically writing for Kristin Scott
Thomas as well right so that might yeah
there's change your approach to the
character yeah and you then the
wonderful thing is they're they're kind
of already inhabiting Clementine
Churchill and Gary's coming out and Gary
will say something very actors kind of
noted which is I'd like to shout in the
scene you know and and I'd be on set and
we're you know two hours from shooting
the scene and I'd say to Gary what do
you think we should shout about he's had
no idea but I had a very quiet scene
before this and I think it would be very
effective if I shouted and for those who
have seen the movie when he does his
first radio broadcast I decided to have
him changing the speech up to the last
second and he shouts at the the BBC guy
who's counting in and saying sir we're
going live to the nation three four two
one and he's shouting one moment damn
you and that's Gary wanted it shouting
moment and it's it's very effective so
it's it's it's all very very
collaborative in the best possible way
mmm any coincidence that both the theory
of everything and then also darker star
if you've read any of their are the
reviews of it something that has been
absolutely fixated on this is
transformative quality of the central
performance so and you know what I love
about it is that it's it's guy open
doing Churchill but it's still
recognizably guy old and it's a it's a
proper and Gary open performance in it
you know going back to Sid Vicious and
what have you
hmm and then similarly dark isn't it
exactly and then with few of everything
as well um you know that was an
incredibly like real deep inhabited
performance really reppin know when
you're writing a lead role is it
possible to calibrate what you're
writing to sort of build in that
transformative potential into it
or is that something that the actor just
brings I mean I don't know maybe the
swing you've-you've so I've fine-tuned
since your earlier screenplays or or if
it's something even though you feel that
you've cracked I think it was who was a
no coward who said the job of the writer
is to write the lines that an actor will
kill to say so right you have to create
the arc you have to create the roadmap
for this actor you have to have played
with all the colors and and then the
actor will say oh my god I can look what
I can do I can do triple somersaults
here I can do this I have all the room
to move to bring everything to the table
it's very much in the writing and then
that's a launchpad for the actor so yeah
it's my attraction to both stories was
the potential to write great roles
especially for everybody across the
board you want to do justice to them all
but I sensed real potential and telling
Stephen Hawking's story I think he's you
know there's he's so unique one of them
in the universe you know
to to have one of the brightest people
on the planet who has to speak through a
computer is is so far-fetched it's James
Bond it's it's you know it's like the
crazy idea of someone's you know sci-fi
fantasy and with Winston Churchill you
know a fantastically huge character with
with all you know the facility with
language his love of the word and the
movie really is a study in the power of
the word it and he's the personification
of that of the proposition that words
can be enlisted to change the world
mobilize the English language drivers
lost yeah yeah yeah the last line which
is Edward L Morrow's line which he wrote
in eulogy for Winston he mobilized the
English language and centered and about
and that was the attraction with that is
is to get an actor who can create that
symphonic music with language and and
the challenge to write for Winston
Churchill to write jokes worthy of
Winston Churchill to put it show him as
a romantic man and what would Winston
Churchill say to Clementine in a private
moment it's all it was all very daunting
but also extremely exciting it's going
to ask that necessity tamping down your
own voice in order to convince him the
express forgive me even just clearly in
terms of how it sounds Stephen Hawking's
voice you know you could play a clip of
Stephen Hawking talking it everyone in
this room would immediately know who he
was Winston Churchill of course he has
that kind of there's this public voice
that he uses to deliver speeches in the
film there's also private voices which
which sort of modulate in between those
in order to convincingly write dialogue
in those voices are you conscious of
removing yourself like you are the kind
of up or we of writing yourself that you
then have to extract yourself from it a
little bit is ventriloquist emotional
ventriloquist
you and it starts with researching their
natural voice which is available to us
through the writings and through clips
we didn't I didn't have any recordings
of Stephens voice pre the computer his
voice was very slurred the first news
clippings of him he was already his
voice had already degenerated heavily so
I had no idea what he sounded like
but I knew how he wrote and he's an
extraordinarily good writer and a
lyrical man so there was there was these
clues and yes you try and you try and do
justice to them when when we finally
showed fear of everything to Stephen we
had a private screening for him and
Kerrigan literally carried him in in his
wheelchair was like like a Roman Emperor
or something on this barge
we sat him down and watched the movie
and I'm very very nervous you can
imagine you know you you've done you
know a portrait of someone else's life
and they're sitting right beside you and
the lights went up at the end and he had
a tear coming down his cheek at the end
and he and he started writing this
verdict on the film takes a majors took
15 minutes white-knuckle 15 minutes
system and he wrote two words broadly
true it's a good review it's a good
review and and and there's a strange
thing and that's another subject is that
is that even though you've invented a
great deal I mean I invented 90% of what
he said and and and half the things that
he does in the movie we have no record
of him doing but he could own it and the
way that then that history almost
follows fiction or and and embraces it
and embodies it there's a great story of
Picasso he did a portrait of Gertrude
Stein and when he finally revealed it to
Gertrude she was horrified because it
wasn't very very flattering and and she
said it doesn't look a thing like me and
to would speak to which Picasso replied
oh but it will let's open this to
questions from the floor if you have a
question please put your hand up do we
have mics we do have mics do me yes
great okay just that with this guy here
perfect thank you very much you're very
much enjoyed what you had to say it I've
got a question about you mentioned
collaboration and what do you think
about script editors I heard of quite a
famous British screenwriter say recently
that he hated them and only trusted to
in their in his life so what do you
think about that process of someone who
can help or do you hate shooting your
babies well my answer would be this I
beseech you and the bowels of Christ
think it possible you may be wrong
and that that would apply to the script
editor and it would apply to me too
you can always be wrong and you can
always learn so I think you're unwise to
throw out advice they're only trying to
help you in the end we what your task is
is to is to take the great ideas and say
thank you and earn them which is the
lovely thing is sometimes people give
you you know million dollar ideas and
and and they walk happily into the
distance and you get to sign sign your
name on it but yeah and and when it's a
it's a terrible idea to lousy one then
that's your job to to identify and come
up with a very good reason but it often
doesn't hurt you to try it out anyway
and sometimes in trying out a lousy idea
you come up with a with a third thing
and and that might prove a way forward
so it's bid pays to be flexible yeah
just a hi Antonia
okay mister pleasure to - my question is
vague and nosy you said that it's they
know you they said that it's okay to
mine one's life for a story um and I've
had a lot of life experience and but I'm
often shy to use it and whereas my sort
of belief in my writing ability is
tenuous I do believe in my life
experience so I suppose my question like
the nosy family must ask what my first
appearance you've had that you've used
but I guess better how do you use your
life experience like how do you use it
respectfully or I'd like can it be
problematic
well I I haven't done anything
particularly autobiographical but I
write about the things I care about I
don't necessarily need to know the
subject matter well because that's
that's part of the joy of of exploring
and research and and getting to know the
subject matter as you learn stuff but
but
Churchill for example as soon as I sort
of embarked on it I thought I I didn't
initially know why I was fascinated by
it and this is where sort of the process
of discovery starts because it becomes a
self journey into saying oh I know what
I have in common with that guy or at
least the story I want to tell about
this man is deeply personal to me why is
it deeply personal well it's got to do
with that proposition I spoke of before
the idea that words matter that we have
to sort of protect them that they they
can change the world you know
and that is every writers every writer
has devoted themselves to that
proposition and and so that thing I
realized is actually an autobiographical
one I would I did not know that however
at the beginning so I hope that answers
your question
and that was an amazing Rachel thanks
very much Anthony hey what's the best
piece of advice you'd give to someone
going from rain plays to write in films
mm-hmm transitioning you've made yeah
they're very similar pretty similar art
forms you you're you know in both you're
getting people in a room you're making
them do things you get you going out the
rider is always that sort of the first
director so the skill sets very similar
but the vocabularies are different and
it took a while for me to stop writing
cinema the way that I would do plays I
thought it was sufficient then to just
have people walk in a room as if it was
a stage and leave it up to the director
to just make it cinematic and then at
the end of the scene people would either
stay or they'd leave and the scenes
would over where they're welcome as well
they'd be sort of long a 10-page scene
four so they were essentially theatrical
in nature that can work there is there's
a scene in here what we just saw part of
it here it's eight pages long which is
unheard of almost in screenwriting so I
love kind of flirting with the
theatrical and and you know Brit
importing that thing that I love which
is just staying in a scene and making it
it long but but yeah you have to learn
the vocabulary of cinema I'm not sure
any of these clips have shown you the
way that that I am increasingly
interested in the cut which is
ostensibly a directors interest in an
editor's interest but it's what you've
learned through the cut that is not a
theatrical device and that's something
I'm yeah I'm still an apprenticeship in
I've seen the opening pages of the
theory of everything screenplay you've
got that cut incredibly telling back
from Stephen Hawking and in the present
yeah right back to him on the bicycle
will you see the kind of stillness and
age through to you know
full speed ahead youth now the way you
wrote that on the page is incredibly
cinematic because you have BAM this
happens BAM Jane does this BAM he looks
and sees these two different things
happening that there's fruit Minh at the
past kind of rearranging things and it's
all intensely visual in order to start
writing like that was that something
that you could kind of in an in a
related we reverse engineer from
watching films that you enjoyed using
her--they words and then yeah absolutely
and it's also you know it's exploring
those devices yourself taking it to a
certain point with one film starting a
new film and say oh that's that's work
to be continued and then you get an
opportunity and the next one to push it
a little further push a little further
and evolve and it gets more exciting
there's a sequencing in darkest hour
where Church was delivering his speech
to to Parliament very long speech and so
it cuts it becomes nonlinear and it
cuts between the composition of the of
the scene and he's dictating it to a
secretary while he's in the bath and
it's continuous so it starts in the
Parliament then the next line is him in
the bath dictating it and then the next
line is secretary typing it then you see
the letters pounding out on the
typewriter and so forth and it was like
oh this is a fantastic and sandbox I'm
in now I can play with all these things
and the reason for getting there
was that I just finished a movie where
I'd been its Bohemian Rhapsody is the
Freddie Mercury story where I had been
playing with this idea that every time
Freddie is going to compose a song you
can cut to him recording it you can cut
to him performing it in a stadium then
you can cut back to him still composing
it and and play with all these
timeframes and so forth and I'd had such
fun playing with all these sort of
devices of intercutting
that I was able on this one too to use
that so that's one of the little areas
I'm exploring so they have a reason for
having multiple screen plays only go up
once as well yeah yeah take another
question
yeah just only from that and then so I
didn't quite from that um I was
wondering when you first started out
what kinds of things did you do to deal
with or cope with not having a boss and
having perhaps not as much time as you
wish you could have for all the ideas
that you have or even you know when you
do find the time that's suddenly when
you're you know two hours staring at a
blank screen but you have the greatest
idea when you're in the middle of
something else and you can't write it
down I mean what kinds of things would
you do to deal with all of that
well my sort of evolution was I I am
I left University and I became
unemployed and in New Zealand the
welfare state is the great patron of the
Arts you think they look after you were
handsomely for about as many years as
you would like and you can work on
dealing with the tyranny of the blank
page and what it is to have a whole day
where you're supposed to write something
and you
idea what you want to write and all that
sort of thing and I remember being
absolutely I was doing an original
creative writing course at university
and I remember going to the to the
professor and knocking on his door and
say it's awful
this writers life is awful you know it's
just hours after hours after hours
everyone else has gone out into the real
world to do real things and I'm just
home you know and there's nothing going
on and there nothing's inciting ideas
and I'm trying to convince myself on the
professional and he said yeah it's tough
isn't it it's a tough tough job and then
he told me the story that you should
create other claims on your time so that
it's not all you're doing and then
you've got then when you're doing this
other thing you'll be thinking I can't
wait to get to my typewriter and and
then when you do get that moment of your
typewriter it'll be a joyous thing
because it'll be oh my god this is a
precious time that I have I so I started
doing that I took a sort of job and I
became a part-time writer for a while
but then I found that that actually I
wanted to be more selfish with the
writing and I got more confident and
comfortable with being alone for all
these hours you know I grew up with
seven children I was one of seven
children and and so I was used to noise
and people being around and and being a
writer or so solitary it takes quite a
lot of time to get used to how to handle
and make yourself productive with all
those empty hours and stuff and so forth
but now it's it's not it's the norm it's
the default to you know everybody clears
out of the house brilliant I know
exactly what I'm gonna do and I know how
I'm gonna fill it and I can sit down and
do eight hours not been in bed an eyelid
but it's it's part of the transition and
to into thinking of yourself as a
professional
I'm Anthony thank you for a brilliant
lecture you mentioned the right to
enslaving their characters and you
mentioned beautiful phrase emotional
ventricular ventriloquism can you talk a
little bit about how you manage to
create characters in the public domain
that have so much veracity and feel as
if they belong in their time because
writers struggle all of us struggle with
wanting the the piece to be expiation
and how do you control the material to
the extent that you do because it's
about period as well as until making
sure that you're writing about them in
their time using the lights by which
they steer you you will mention that to
me earlier hmm yeah how do you get it
right
how does it feel authentic how does it
feel of it style and not anachronistic
it's it's research it's it's dreaming
yourself into that world often when I
turn projects down it's a phrase I lead
on a lot I'm sorry I don't think I can
dream myself into this world but when
you do when you work creatively excited
by it usually you feel it's it's in you
to use that American expression it's in
your wheelhouse
it's not in your timeframe it might be
centuries ago but you but the themes the
universal things that timeless things
you feel you've got a grip on getting
getting hold of the language of the day
is interesting I'm just working on a
Benedict Cumberbatch movie for his
company about a 400 year old man so he's
born in the time of Shakespeare and I'm
spending my days trying to write called
Shakespeare at the moment it's awful
because that you know the bar is so high
that has never been higher so it's a
tough proposition but I imagine that
that and that the research is still
ongoing as to how you would
someone from a working-class background
living in the gloucester area would have
spoken four hundred years ago we don't
have any particular records of that so
you'll sort of creating a reality that
that you're hoping people will buy into
its research it's its sensitivity it's
using your instincts yes I must say that
the darkest hour is my favorite film
this year I think it's amazing
um one of the things that I think is so
extraordinary about the way you've
written it is how strong all the other
parts are now Gary opens part obviously
it's amazing
Churchill it's wonderful but when you
look at Steven Tulane playing Halifax or
Ronnie pickup playing
Chamberlain it really rounded and strong
and I don't imagine that Gary Oldman's
performance would be as strong if you
hadn't written so many actually
wonderful parts around them well they
just want to ask you what you can write
next well we know you're writing for
Benedict for four hundred years but what
are the other four scripts that you're
well with shoot we're shooting one at
the moment Anthony Hopkins is playing
Pope Benedict and the wonderful Jonathan
Pryce is playing Pope Francis and it's a
sort of it's again a dialectic - you
couldn't find two more opposite types of
people both charged with us with this
spiritual leadership of 1.2 billion
people they're both meant to be
infallible but they can't agree on
anything
and I thought that was an interesting
opportunity for a sort of papal
theological smackdown and we'll see how
that one goes that's that's shooting
right now again it's it's its theme so
get on I think I know how to tackle that
that those those themes interest me I
think I have something to say on those
I'm doing a John Lennon Yoko Ono love
story we're producing it with Yoko Ono
which is an absolute privilege although
she fell asleep on me when I went to see
her
but we have all of John's music and
setting John's music within the context
of the 60s and what the 60s meant why
why the the themes of the 60s meant so
much to those people who lived through
it is an incredible privilege doing the
Benedict Cumberbatch movie working with
Alex Gibney the great documentary
filmmaker on a Vietnam War movie how
many of our numbered now it's for ya
real people so you're writing or almost
biographical films again do you like
doing those rather than fictional films
yeah the the benedict cumberbatch one
isn't ya know this the four hundred year
old men I I am I've seen to have found
myself quite a happy situation to be
enough of sustained portraiture just
walked around the Hockney exhibition of
all those portraits I seem to be in a
hot new phase or you know but didn't
deserve Shakespeare to focus on
portraiture so I'm very happily doing
what I'm doing at the moment and it and
just because they're historical and
famous doesn't mean you can't make them
contemporary and and interesting and
personal so it's sometimes it's like the
poet's say when you write a sonnet the
very the very fact that there are severe
limitations on what you can do can be
actually very liberating and I'm kind of
finding them yes it comes the end of our
Q&A session thank you for watch this
videos thank you for them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]